Концепція фундаменталізму по суті пов'язана з
концепцією вимірювання в квантовій механіці
до того, як квантова механіка була розроблена
вчені загалом вважали
що якщо в тебе є система, яка
перебуває в певному стані
і ти проводиш вимірювання — отримаєш
цілком визначений результат
у квантовій механіці це вже не так — система може
перебувати в цілком чітко визначеному стані
і проте при певних
вимірюваннях ти можеш отримувати випадкові результати
щоб проілюструвати цю концепцію
мені треба ввести поняття суперпозиції
суперпозиція — це концепція, яка не є суто квантовою
вона ґрунтується на відображенні системою
кількох лінійних комбінацій станів
одночасно, і можна уявити це
наприклад як радіохвилю, що несе
багато різних частот — у цьому немає нічого
суто квантового
квантового присмаку суперпозиції надає саме
вимірювання системи
проілюструю це на прикладі
уяви, що маєш систему стрілок
і ти підготував систему
так, що всі стрілки вказують вліво
і потім ти йдеш і
ставиш системі запитання: ти вгору чи вниз?
і оскільки стрілка вказує вліво, що можна
виразити і описати
як лінійну суперпозицію між
«вгору» і «вниз» — ти отримаєш
результати: п'ятдесят відсотків «вгору»
і п'ятдесят відсотків «вниз», коли ставиш питання: вгору чи вниз?
ти отримуєш такий результат від системи
і потім можна підготувати
інший стан системи, де половина стрілок
вказує вгору, а половина —
вниз, і ставиш те саме питання
і отримуєш той самий результат
це дві дуже різні системи
а ти отримав однакову інформацію
від обох
то як можна визначити різницю між ними?
системи насправді дуже різні
бо в першому випадку ти підготував систему в
чистому стані, і є питання, яке ти
можеш поставити системі й отримати детермінований
а не випадковий результат — це питання «вліво чи вправо?»
і вона скаже тобі: сто відсотків вліво
у другому випадку немає жодного питання, яке ти
можеш поставити, щоб отримати сто відсотків детермінований
результат, бо це суміш
тож якщо запитаєш «вліво чи вправо?»
буде випадково, бо половина вгору
а половина вниз; якщо запитаєш «вгору чи вниз?»
те саме — буде п'ятдесят відсотків
як це пов'язане з квантовою випадковістю?
можна уявити це
подібним до підкидання монети — буде орел чи решка
але це не схоже на підкидання монети взагалі
бо коли підкидаєш монету
єдина причина, чому ти не знаєш результату наперед
полягає в тому, що ти не знаєш
силу, з якою підкинув монету, кут у момент
кидка, умови в приміщенні
тощо — тобто якби ти знав усі ці
змінні, ти міг би передбачити орел чи решку
змінні, які приховані від спостерігача
і протягом багатьох років вчені вважали, що існують
схожі приховані змінні в квантовій механіці, які
проявляються як випадковість
і лише завдяки
основоположній праці Джона Белла у шістдесятих роках вдалося
довести, що це не так
і тепер кожен фізик
визнає, що не існує жодної
теорії прихованих змінних, сумісної з квантовою механікою
отже, це справді так: коли вимірюєш систему
природа відкриває результат
і скільки б я про це не думав
це все одно вражає